hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel it is currently a weekday after
work which means I am extremely tired uh
trying to grind out some videos before I
go away for the weekend going to Indiana
for the Indie 500 so if you happen to be
watching this on a Sunday it means I'm
probably black out in the middle of a
field somewhere uh but in the meantime
let's go ahead and learn about some
systems assign So today we're going to
be talking about video group chats uh
specifically something like Zoom or
Skype without further Ado let's jump
into it all right so let's go ahead and
get into things so the past that uh or
like the last time that I made this
video I was basically going ahead and
saying that I thought it would be kind
of unrealistic to ask for a systems
design interview and as I make it this
time I'm actually starting to kind of go
back on that thought because I think
that there are probably a couple of
aspects of this video that you couldn't
possibly be expected to know but I do
actually think that um you know if you
had to extrapolate out this problem just
using some reason and you were asked
less specifically about you know like
actually transmitting video over the
Internet it's actually not too
unreasonable of a video to make so let's
go ahead and get into things so if
you're not familiar with zoom or Skype
if you've been under a rock for the last
few years uh here is an example of what
it might look like typically what you'll
have is some sort of video call as I've
displayed on the iPad as you can see
here's an example of me at my beach
house mansion sitting at my desk got a
nice infinity pool SL ocean in the
outside and then we've got Karina cof
also on the call with Alexander d Ario
and also anad armos I can't show what
their screens are displaying because uh
you know it would not be fair to them
obviously this was a screenshot taken
off of my real computer would not want
to violate their privacy okay so let's
actually formalize some problem
requirements number one is we can
support both one-on-one and group video
chats number two should be that we can
support pretty large calls up to 100
people at a time which uh if you're a
working software engineer like myself
you'll know that these do happen pretty
frequently uh number three is that uh we
should be able to record all of these
video calls from some sort of
centralized server or you know on the
back end right it shouldn't necessarily
be me using my computer to do it that
can overload my client so again we
should be able to upload those to the
cloud for later access cool so the first
thing that we're going to do is start
off by quickly doing a refresher on
networking uh if you watch the video
game video that I made last week uh you
should hopefully have this pretty fresh
in your mind but if you didn't because
you're an and you don't like
watching these videos in order uh
basically we've got TCP and UDP uh TCP
has all sorts of protections involved
with sending packets over the network
this involves trying to send them in
order right if a client receives a
packet from someone else what it can do
is say oh you know what I'm actually
missing a sequence number that I should
have can you send me that one first
before I apply this guy number two is
that you resend dropped packets uh which
is another nice optimization so you
don't just drop things and never send
them again uh number three is that we
initially establish a connection via a
three-way handshake so clients aren't
receiving any packets from people that
they haven't agreed to receive them from
and number four is that we also have
congestion control and flow control so
congest congestion control is when I'm
sending packets I'm going to limit how
many I send flow control is the receiver
is basically giving me back information
saying like whoa there don't send
anymore I'm already having trouble
processing these cool the next thing is
that as far as we are concerned with
video chats we don't actually really
care about getting every single package
right so if every imagine every packet
is a frame or something like that it is
okay for me to drop a couple of frames
here and there and not get them back the
reason being that you know if I'm doing
a video chat and uh I lose a frame and
then I get the next frame I don't want
the old frame again I don't care anymore
you've just buffered and whatever it's
done now so generally speaking what we
actually want to use here is UDP because
UDP is going to be a little bit faster
because it doesn't have all of these
protections that TCP has and it's not
like we really need them for video
chatting anyway so UDP is probably going
to be the way to go here at least for
the actual sending of the video and the
audio itself for other stuff perhaps not
cool next we're going to be talking
about peer-to-peer communication so you
might think to yourself well obviously
for something like a video chat or just
with networking in general the way to
make things as fast as possible is to
communicate with two computers directly
right you want to get as little involved
in the middle because that always adds
overhead in terms of them actually
processing those packets then sending
them out again it takes a little bit so
ideally if I'm video chatting with you
we want to be sending each other packets
directly right well the question is is
this actually always going to be the
case so maybe if it's the two of us
together however if it's us two and your
entire company now all of a sudden we're
all sending one another packets and that
can add a lot of load on our client
devices so that is a problem right there
and also what if we wanted to actually
record this video footage well now all
of a sudden basically whoever is doing
that recording probably needs to be
ingesting all of the video footage from
all these different places right it
could be up to 100 and then actually
compiling them together and that could
be a very expensive operation too so it
may not necessarily be something that we
want to be doing that being said for
just the sake of a one-on-one video chat
peer-to-peer communication does seem
ideal so let's say it was a one-on-one
call how would we actually go ahead and
do a peer-to-peer
communication for me to cover a topic
like this I think it is a good prere
requisite that we first understand
something in modern networking known as
Network address translation or n for
short so basically the gist here is that
every single device that we use that's
connected to the network has some sort
of IP address right however you might
think that you know uh your laptop and
your smart TV on your Wi-Fi have
separate IP addresses and technically
that's true however in reality when they
go and communicate with the public
network which is basically anyone that's
not on your Wi-Fi uh they're both
basically being abstracted away under
under one IP address known as your
public IP address so basically you have
some sort of natat device like this over
here that's going to keep a mapping
right uh from B to a where B is your
public IP address and then a is going to
be your private IP address now all the
devices on your local network can see
each other's private IP addresses but we
want to basically mask that private IP
address publicly simply for the sake
that um you know it's it's going to
allow us to add extra security number
one so that no one has direct access to
your IP address and number two and also
pretty important is that if we're using
ipv4 again we're really getting into the
weeds here probably not that important
for your standard systems design
interview uh we have a limited number of
possible addresses that we can use and
so as a result uh we have to figure out
a way to make the public IP address
space smaller and the way that we do
that is basically by saying oh for every
single local network you just get one
public IP address cool so hopefully that
makes sense but the gist is you know
we've got some Nat device here our
client device has one IP address a the N
device is exposing it as some other IP
address B with a certain port and then
uh it goes to the server says hey I'm
contacting you on IP address B the
server reaches back out to B the nap
device maps that back to a and then that
goes right back to the client so the
gist is the reason we call it Network
address translation is because the nap
device is doing that translating from
public address back to private
address so let's continue talking about
the n space a little bit because this is
important for how two clients can
actually directly communicate with one
another uh as far as Nat is concerned
there is another concept here known as
the stun conserver uh the stun server so
the n in stun server actually does stand
for natat uh but I can't remember the
full acronym and frankly it's not
important I'm kind of uh you know going
on a bit of a tangent here but uh I
think it is relevant for the rest of the
video it's just that you know if I were
an interviewer and I were to ask you
this question I wouldn't expect you to
just like be able to conjure up uh the
concept of net unless you were someone
who's been working with networks for a
while cool so gist is you would reach
out to the stun server right both
clients can reach out to it figure out
their private IP addresses or rather the
private IP address of the other party
and then all of a sudden now they can
communicate directly problem is this
doesn't always even work depending on
the KN device that you're using uh stun
just may not uh you know expose your
private IP address properly and you may
just always have to communicate through
that KN device in which case your
latency is always going to go down
because now we have an extra on the
network regardless let's go talk about
an actual centralized chat server CU
like I mentioned when we have a group
chat the actual feasibility of using uh
peer-to-peer communication directly
tends to go down quite a bit so what is
the main benefit of the central chat
server like I mentioned each client
really only has to listen to and send
videos to one place and this is pretty
crucial because if we had to listen to a
100 different other clients and we had
to send video to 100 different other
clients and we were doing this on
something like a mobile phone you could
expect that battery to die pretty darn
quickly cool what is the con well our
server is going to be under a bunch of
load right if we've got 100 different
people sending video at say 24 frames
per second all to this server at 1080p
uh that server is going to get pretty
overloaded so how do we actually want to
be able to handle this video on the
centralized server uh so that we can
basically maximize uh the efficiency of
this server and minimize the amount of
load on it
well let's take a look at option number
one option number one is that the
centralized server is going to take in
all the streams from the uh from all the
clients and basically compile it down
into one simple video right so we take
all of these frames merge them together
somehow and then export that out all to
uh the clients that are interested in
our video chat stream so there are a few
cons to this approach which is
ultimately why we're not going to go
with it number one is that actually
doing this transpilation on the server
is itself going to use a lot of CPU load
so that's not ideal and then number two
is that every single client has to watch
the same Stream So something like this
might be acceptable for twitch where
you're really only looking at one stream
at a time but for something like video
chatting we want all customized
experiences right if I'm a teacher
presenting maybe I'm a student uh and I
want to see the Whiteboard as the big
screen and not the teacher's face and
someone else uh if the teacher is a
baddie might want to see that teacher's
face so you know that's how it goes
sometimes so the question is how can we
actually improve this
well now we're going to talk about
something known as selective forwarding
which is definitely something that we
see quite a bit in actual video chat
applications so option two allows us to
have a customizable experience per user
because basically what we're going to do
now is only send clients the streams
they actually care about and in the
resolutions that they care about them so
let's go ahead and make an example here
let's say our Zoom call looks something
like this right we've got all the best
world leaders on one Zoom call we've got
Trump Kim Jong-un Putin and Stalin he
came back from the dead so let's imagine
that in my particular view I've got
Trump as the big guy and so over a
websocket I can communicate with the
centralized server and say hey on my
particular view I want Trump as an HD
stream I want Kim Jong as an SD stream
Putin as an SD stream and Stalin as an
SD stream if I was getting HD feeds for
all of these guys that would be a lot
more load on my server and that would be
not great it would just overload the
network unnecessarily and then it would
also have to basically just like down
sample all of those um streams to a
lower resolution so it doesn't help me
to do that at all I just want the lower
resolution variant if for whatever
reason you know I were to put Stalin on
the big stream and Trump goes back here
then you know we can change that over
such that Stalin is HD Trump is SD and
the way that we would do that is just by
having the web socket between my client
and the main server uh reflect that and
the server is going to cach it such that
as new frames come in it knows what to
send me
so let's keep talking about this
selective forwarding a little bit
because there is actually going to be a
little bit more Nuance here the question
now becomes if the server can send me
multiple different types of streams
right or multiple different resolutions
or multiple encodings or anything like
that again I don't really want to get
into video specifics here a because I
don't know that much about them and B
because I don't expect your interviewer
would expect you to either how is it
that the client is actually going to
send all of the data that the central
server needs to do selective forwarding
so option number one is the client sends
a single stream to the central server
the central server basically converts it
to a bunch of other formats or
resolutions or anything that you might
need and then it's going to basically
send it out to all of the clients that
care about it so this is good because
the client only has to send one stream
right at the same time it's not so good
because the server has to do a bunch
more work and that we really don't want
because that is going to be the failure
scenario right if our server is going
down all the time we can't have a video
chat in the first place uh regardless of
how much load is on the client so that
leads us to option number two the client
still only has to send one stream to our
uh to our Central server however this
time it actually goes through an
intermediary server so this intermediary
server can do all of the processing on
that stream to convert it to multiple
different resolutions and then send that
to the central server now in theory this
seems like a really really great deal
because uh you know the client now only
has to send one stream and Additionally
the central Server doesn't have to do
any extra processing on it so this idea
of like a proxy server seems to work
really nicely at the same time when you
introduce yet another intermediary
server that is just more latency and
more time that it takes for all of these
frames to actually get to the central
server for it to send them out and so
it's going to cause more lag in your
video chats so in reality what we often
see most of these video chat
applications do is take approach number
three which is that basically the client
is still going to do all the encoding
but it's going to do it all locally so
maybe instead of sending out one stream
now we're going to send out three
streams so the client is going to have
to do a little bit more work which is
unfortunate but ideally it shouldn't be
so much because you're only doing it for
one stream at a time so we send these
multiple streams all the way to our
Central server and then right there it
means a little bit more work for the
client device but no extra load on the
central server to do more encoding and
uh you know now it has all the
information that it needs right off the
bat to send that right back to all the
client
so this is the approach that often gets
taken now basically everything I've
described so far is uh known as uh web
RTC which is basically some technology
that abstracts all of this away from us
uh but again I think that you know
mentioning or having to have that
knowledge in an actual systems design
interview uh would be pretty unnecessary
because the whole point is to interview
for generalists and see if they can
recognize the patterns
here cool now let's talk about
partitioning and replication because
obviously this is going to be important
for any time that we have a centralized
server so the main idea here is that you
know if we have a bunch of different
video calls ideally we want one
centralized server per call so what do
we do well we Shard on chat ID that
should be pretty simple we can use
consistent hashing to make sure that uh
you know every server is getting a
relatively even amount of load it is
possible I guess in theory that one of
these servers for a given chat may
actually getting uh be getting so much
load that we have to partition it out
even further and if we really did need
to do that I guess what we could do is
use two or three chat servers basically
uh spread out which users have to send
video footage to which server and then
now every single user is listening to
say two or three servers instead of just
one so you do have to do a little bit
more work on the read path but the work
on the right path stays the same and
then this way uh that Central server
basically only has to uh keep track of
all the configuration that it needs for
a couple of different users at the time
cool so the next aspect of this is going
to be replication how do we make sure
that our Central server if it goes down
uh our video chat uh does not completely
Crash and Burn I guess the gist here is
that what we can do is use centralized
servers in kind of like a active passive
configuration as we've seen with load
balancers in the past so what this
really means is basically you know we
have some passive backup that just sits
there doing nothing we've got a
zookeeper cluster that's constantly
getting heartbeats from our main node
and then if our main Central server goes
down uh the backup basically uh you know
says to zookeeper oh you know what I'm
actually going to be the primary now and
then everyone reestablishes their
websocket connection with the the backup
because they're going to hear from
zookeeper also saying hey uh this has
just changed for this particular node
and then now all of a sudden we're good
to go so yep that should be simple
enough uh we've seen this pattern plenty
on this channel cool another thing to
note is that we don't really need to
keep any state on the backup the reason
being that all of this is pretty much
stateless right we're basically just
forwarding UDP streams You could argue
that uh the state of what streams each
user wants uh could maybe be pre-cached
in the backup to go for like a more
seamless transition but at the same time
I think that on reestablishing those
websockets uh this is not going to be a
particularly large data model and each
user could just go ahead and tell the
backup uh which streams it wants to
perform selective
forwarding okay the final aspect of this
problem like I mentioned is to talk
about video recording so the first thing
to note is that we don't want to be
doing this on the central server this is
something that I said I would do on the
central server on maybe another thread
in uh my last version of this video or
the last version of this series and I do
regret saying that so let's go ahead and
change that up basically the gist is we
can have other servers that subscribe to
the video call and also perform the
encoding that we need to actually make
this recording and put it in S3 so let's
say that we just need one recording
right um we just need one version of the
recording where you know it's like the
active speaker is always going to be the
big frame on the video chat and uh you
know that's just going to be what we
have access to after the fact that's
fine we can probably do that easily
Enough by having our Central server here
our recording server here and then the
recording server is going to take in all
those frames you know do some work on
them on another thread and then upload
them to S3 easy enough however sometimes
it may be the case that you don't just
want you know one version of the zoom
call but you actually want like full
highdefinition views of every single
user stream throughout the duration of
the call if for whatever reason this
were going to be the case it may be the
case that this guy right here the
recording server could get overloaded
right because now instead of just doing
selective forwarding where it's like you
know one HD stream and maybe one SD
stream and maybe one more SD stream you
might need 100 fullon HD streams and
that could overload this guy that would
be
bad so like we mentioned uh you know
being able to get all user streams could
be too expensive why don't we go ahead
and distribute this thing so to do that
what we would basically do is we would
have multiple different recording
servers still basically doing the same
exact thing as clients right they would
establish over here via websocket which
streams they actually want access to so
maybe this guy gets uh you know the
stream for user one in
HD this guy over here gets a stream for
user two in HD this guy over here gets
the stream for user three in HD they can
go ahead and cash those throw them in
Kafka that's right Jordan's back he's
using Kafka we sharded this queue on our
recording ID or rather the chat ID
because you know we just need them all
to be together if they're from the same
chat so they can be combined eventually
and then we've got some stateful stream
consumer the reason I say stateful is
because if this guy were to go down uh
it would be bad if we had to restart
reading all the frames from Kafka it
would be great if uh we could just pull
a checkpoint from S3 and continue
encoding from there and then the saful
stream consumer will in turn sync the
final recordings over to S3 cool uh the
one other thing to note is that you know
because we have all of these uh frames
coming from different sources it's
possible that if one of them is a little
bit slow to consume that footage that
they might not be perfectly aligned in
Kafka right this guy might upload way
before or maybe 5 seconds before this
guy down here and so if that's to be the
case you know how does uh the stream
consumer actually know well uh you know
at this Frame this guy has lined up with
this guy well fortunately every frame is
going to have some Tim stamp from the
central server so the central server can
actually just export that time stamp
with the frame and that way eventually
this stream consumer can basically use
the timestamp of each frame to properly
align all of the
footage cool so let's go ahead and look
at our full on diagram over here
basically if if we have a call client on
the Left Right This Guy's our chat
client the first thing that he's going
to do is go to the load balancer with
his chat ID now the chat ID is probably
something that's going to be encoded in
the actual link that he clicks to open
the zoom so once he does that the load
balancer which listens to zookeeper is
going to use the consistent hashing
policy to map him over to our chat
server once we have a chat server we're
going to do two things we're going to
establish a websocket connection and
this is going to be for the selective
forwarding
because the chat server needs to know
which streams I want and then in
addition we're also going to start
subscribing to UDP feed so the UDP feed
over here right this guy is going to be
the incoming frames and audio of other
users simultaneously our user also has
to send a few variants of their stream
over to the chat server maybe we've got
a 1080 a 720p and a 480p and all three
of those are three different UDP streams
that the chat server can go ahead and
ingest in addition we've got our passive
chat server over here which again is
listening to zookeeper basically just
waiting for the chat server to go down
and if it does it'll take over claim its
place in Zookeeper and then we can
proceed as normal finally as far as
recording goes let's imagine that we did
in fact want to uh process a lot of
video footage here so much so that we
needed multiple nodes to actually take
uh in the recording data so imagine now
that we have stream Ingress server
number one and two they're both
listening to UDP feed they're both
connected as well via websocket to
basically say what exactly it is that
they want right and again you know if we
really want to get into the weeds here
they can also use some sort of
consistent hashing policy such that
server one is responsible for one range
of users footage and server two is
responsible for another range of users
footage but the gist is they're going to
take in all this footage they're going
to throw it in Kafka with its Tim stamp
which we partition on our chat ID and
then over here in our stateful consumer
I use flank use whatever you want you
know I love flank sorry uh basically
we're going to go ahead and cash all of
this stuff combine it uh however it is
that we want to do so and then finally
sync it to S3 for later access well guys
I hope you enjoyed this video I
personally am falling asleep so I'm
sorry for stuttering a little bit uh but
hopefully it did actually make sense
this time around anyways enjoy your
night and have a great day